while AMD's 400 and 500 series video
cards were great value GPUs they were
aimed at budget gamers this meant that
Nvidia's high-end 10 series cards have
remained unchallenged until now with
AMD's new Vega GPU architecture the
company is back in the enthusiasts mix
and says that its RX Vega 64 can compete
with Nvidia's $550 GeForce GTX 1084 $50
less but is it worth half a grand let's
find out
[Music]
we're reviewing the reference RX Vega 64
which is a dual slot card that measures
ten point five inches and comes with the
traditional black shroud coupled with a
thirty millimeter fan one concern
against it up front is that it's a 295
watt TDP cord this is unprecedented for
any single GPU that we've ever reviewed
and it requires a beefy 750 watt PSU
with to a pin power connectors in terms
of ports the RX Vega 64 includes three
DisplayPort 1.4 connections and one HDMI
output the RX Vega 64 partially gets its
name from the fact that it has 64
compute units in terms of core and boost
clocks its clocked at 12 74 megahertz
and 1546 megahertz respectively aim D
says the card is tuned for high
frequencies and should be able to boost
higher if it gets adequate power and
cooling it uses a gigabytes of second
generation high bandwidth video memory
this new vm technology allows it to
reach up to 483 gigabytes per second of
memory bandwidth that's a lot and should
help it push game textures efficiently
which can come in handy at 4k like
resolution the arcs Vegas 64 is a 12
point 7 teraflop card which trumps
Nvidia's equivalent GPU by 3.8 teraflops
but don't assume that tells the entire
performance story for that let's dig
into the benchmarks since AMD claims
that the RX Vegas 64 is competitive with
Nvidia's GeForce GTX 1080 we're gonna
make direct comparisons against it we
also tested it against the slightly
lower ng TX 1070 and Nvidia's flagship
gtx 980ti to give you additional context
we tested all the cards using the same
system at three resolutions we also ran
each benchmark at their respective necks
settings to really stress test the cards
3d mark 11 extreme is a 1080p test
that's designed to measure GPUs DirectX
11 performance the RX Vegas 64 scored
13% worse than the GTX 1080 here but
spoiler warning AMD's card doesn't
really live up to its full potential at
1080p it seems like the resolution isn't
demanding enough for it to fully flex
its muscles the RX Vegas 64 performs a
bit strangely in the rest of our other
1080p tests it beats the GeForce GTX
1080 in our shadow of mordor and more by
5.5 percent respectively but loses to
the lower tier gtx 1070 in BioShock
Infinite by a respective 10%
the GT X 1080 beats the RX Vega 64 by
8.2% and tomb raider and overall it
seems like the GT x 1080 is better for
standard HD gaming a consolation prize
for AMD's card is that the RX Vegas 64
never dipped below 80 average fps in any
of our 1080p tests this indicates that
it's generally overkill for 1920 by 1080
unless you have a really high refresh
rate monitor moving up to 2560 by 1440
another popular gaming resolution
GeForce GTX 1080 continues to show its
overall edge by repeatedly beating a
Indies card in Tomb Raider BioShock
Infinite and Unigine Valley ambe's card
does once again outperform the GT X 1080
in shadow of mordor by 1.7 percent
respectively though 3840 by 2160 is
where the RX Vegas 64 really starts to
pull ahead ambe's GPU beats the GTX 1080
here in all of our 4k tests oddly enough
one of the biggest leads comes by way of
BioShock Infinite which is where the GTX
1080 really thrashed the RX Vega at the
lower resolution at 4k video Ram can
really bottleneck a GPU since it has to
push so many high resolution assets one
of the likely reasons that the RX Vegas
64 really comes into its own here is
that I can efficiently do so with its
very high memory bandwidth while the RX
Vegas 64 is faster than the GTX 1080 at
4k it's still going to struggle in the
most graphically demanding games like
Deus Ex mankind divided in Valve's V our
benchmark the RX Vegas 64 performed 11%
of worse than the GTX 1080 this suggests
Nvidia's card is better for virtual
reality some people were hoping the
AMD's leading Vega GPU would outperform
the $700 of gtx 980ti
those people may be disappointed with
the RX Vega 64 but it does largely live
up to Andy's claim that it's competitive
with the GTX 280 as a matter of fact it
runs slightly better at 4k given our
results it won't be able to max out
every single 4k game though aim D says
that it's an ideal card to max out the
ultra wide 34 40 by 1440p monitors and
we'd agree and say that's probably worth
sweet sputters while the RX Vegas 64 is
a really good card it's a bit hard to
get super excited when it's coming out
more than 14 months after the GTX 1080
and doesn't completely trounce it it
also consumes a confusing amount of
power still this doesn't prevent the car
from being arguably fast
than the GTX 1084 $50 less the ball is
now an Nvidia score to respond with
either a price drop or a sooner reveal
of its upcoming voltage GPUs because AMD
is back with a compelling choice for
enthusiast gamers for the full in-depth
review check out our written review on
GameSpot calm if you liked this video
make sure you check out our video review
of aim these 500 and 570 GPUs also make
sure to give us a like and subscribe for
more thanks for watching